you know very often in our world today
we are told that we must disbelieve our
lying eyes truths that are right in
front of us plain as day are to be
rejected as mere figments of our
imagination the most obvious realities
become conspiracy theories statements of
basic fact or propaganda we run fact
checks on self evidence certitudes and
the fact check corrects the record
reality is not reality we are informed
the sun is not in the sky water is not
wet there is no gravity
we're not living on planet earth
nothing that you see is real
the self-assigned arbiters of truth
assure us
don't rely on your own common sense
close your eyes which so often deceive
you anyway and let them guide you to and
fro let them be your window into the
world
they will tell you what is real and what
isn't
and they
our culture's truth deciders have
decided that all of the recent talk
about grooming is absurd outrageous
offensive bigoted it's all just a bunch
of anti-gay fear-mongering they say
and the claim that disney disney of all
companies disney not disney the claim
that they're actively grooming and
sexualizing children is the most
ludicrous falsehood of all they insist
that's why they tell us the move in
florida last week to take away disney's
special tax privileges was a
catastrophic overreaction
worse it was an all-out assault on the
first amendment somehow
i mean disney has no constitutional
right to the extra privileges afforded
it by florida but um now that it has
those privileges taking them away is
unconstitutional we're told
it's an unnecessary act of retribution
disney didn't do anything to deserve it
to deserve this
poor helpless disney that
200 billion damsel in distress
disney now needs its own prince charming
to come rescue it but unfortunately
disney declared years ago that those
kinds of characters are misogynistic
retrograde gender essentialist
and so there is no one left to save them
they are abandoned to the clutches of
the dastardly desantis a man who we are
reminded
completely made up this whole issue of
disney grooming children that is
entirely fictional
and yet
there are of course many examples we can
point to and have pointed to many times
recently of disney endorsing encouraging
and often actively engaging in
predatory grooming practices towards
children
we've gone through the partial catalog
enough to prove the point i think
but
we've missed one example
one example so disgusting and twisted
and over the top
that it's really the only one we need
the conversation could begin and end
right here
anyone defending disney
anyone claiming that the grooming label
is unfair or overboard
anybody including people on the right
panicking over florida's revocation of
disney's legal privileges should be
confronted with this clip
this is from an episode of good morning
america on abc which is of course owned
by disney
because when we're talking about disney
we're not just talking about disney
world and mickey mouse and uh the little
mermaid we're talking about all of the
media properties that disney owns
like abc
now what you're about to see happened on
live tv
on a major network
in front of a live studio audience
i didn't dig this up from the darkest
fringes of the internet this is as
mainstream as it gets
it's what disney promotes and supports
so here's the time when good morning
america featured an 11 year old boy in
drag
the child's stage name is desmond is
amazing
and everyone in the building including
the hosts including michael strahan
who's one of the hosts
seem to very much agree that what you're
about to see is indeed amazing
here it is
please welcome desmond annapolis aka
desmond is amazing
[Applause]
here we go
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
i love that you love root beer caffeine
free i can get on board with that my mom
doesn't like me drinking caffeine
does it make you hyper
yeah me too they don't like when i drink
caffeine either
but jasmine you're one of the youngest
and first drag queen slash kids
i've heard that you've gotten messages
from young adults who look up to you for
being who you are
what are some of the notes you've gotten
some of the notes i've gotten are like
that you inspire me very much and i wish
i could have had the support that you
have um when i was a child
now
if you're listening to the audio podcast
you have been spared the worst of what
we just experienced altogether
um though you can't fully appreciate
just how dark and deranged it was
because desmond the 11 year old drag kid
quote unquote
prances out
on stage in women's clothes
makeup caked on his face
dances for the adoring crowd of grown
adults at one point lays himself out
prostrate on the ground on the stage
while creepy michael strahan stares and
claps
then he sits down for a lengthy
interview
and later in this segment on this
segment that was aired on disney's abc
even though disney totally is not trying
to groom children at all
later in the segment three adult drag
queens are brought out on stage with
desmond in their full cross-dressing
costumes woman face fully on and they
proceed to give desmond gifts of makeup
and quote-unquote dance classes
want to tell us what's out watch well i
i see i i drew desmond a little
green-haired lady it's it's it's for you
it's to bring you good luck and
prosperity in your future
[Applause]
and to eat iceberg lettuce good roughage
okay there you go
with tomatoes and cucumbers absolutely
and i brought you a gift basket of some
of my favorite actually you know what
let me actually hand it to you because i
think you need to have it in your hands
it is some of my favorite makeup
essentials that i use always
i will never understand
so many things about what we're seeing
here but one of them is that is how
every woman is not insulted
when they see
the drag queens and i know so many women
are in fact
but every woman should be insulted
because because i mean leaving aside the
worst part about this which is the fact
that there's a kid there we'll get back
to a second but um you see that and like
that's what they think of you that's
that's their impression of you
it is no different from blackface it is
female blackface
it is uh it is a mockery of womanhood
this is what they think
you are
this is their female impression
and if it seems cartoonish and degrading
that's because it is
and that's how they see femininity as a
degraded cartoonish
thing
by the way if you're wondering where the
father is in all of this um surprisingly
or maybe not surprisingly he is in the
picture he's literally in the picture
he's in the audience during this segment
he's one of the greasy disgusting old
men staring and clapping while the young
boys paraded around and cross-dressing
burlesque gear
desmond may as well be wearing a
sandwich board sign which announces i am
a sexual abuse victim because his abuse
is on full display for all to see and
the audience loves every minute of it
and abc loves it and disney loves it
now those who wish to mitigate and
minimize this will point out that this
segment aired back in 2018. this is not
new
it's old news
i've already been told this after i
posted this segment on twitter
people say this is old news why are you
posting this
because to them apparently child sexual
abuse doesn't matter if it happened a
few years ago
but maybe they'd have a point that its
relevance to the current news cycle is
minimized if
there already been an overwhelming
public outrage about this spectacle and
everybody involved was fired
and disney had issued a public apology
and there was already a reckoning of
that sort but no such reckoning occurred
nobody was fired
nobody apologized
there wasn't even any real backlash
michael strahan got a major contract
extension last year after this everybody
involved rode happily into the sunset
except for desmond himself who is still
being paraded around and used as a prop
by the lgbt left and his evil
exploitative ghoulish abusive parents
desmond has been sent into gay clubs to
dance for money
that's a real thing
this child in drag has danced at gay
clubs at night
while grown adult
gay men throw money at him on stage
he's appeared in videos with adult gay
men where he pantomimes snorting
ketamine off of his hand
something that no 11 year old should
know how to do or be aware of
um just for reference here's that moment
anyone can do drag
everyone can do drag everyone your mom
can do jack
what has this world come to it's come to
a world where drag kids actually exist
and people do ketamine on a couch
and people do ketamine on my couch
yeah so he's uh that's during some kind
of facebook live or something and he's
done a lot of these where he's where he
appears with adult um cross-dressing men
and uh very often in the videos he
appears to be on drugs now that's not
something that a 11 year old
should know anything about do ketamine
on a couch and then he
but why was he doing that because at the
very least he sees it happen all the
time
and um nothing is being done to stop it
on the contrary disney is there to
celebrate and promote it
meanwhile the whole concept of drag kids
and the mixing of drag queens and kids
with things like drag queen story hour
that's only become more mainstream more
common more popular since 2018.
once the left learned that it could put
something like that on a network
television morning show
that was actually a a pivotal i believe
a pivotal moment in our culture was that
lots of people never knew that it even
happened
but that they could put that on good
morning america
um and there's no backlash
because of it
nobody even complains well they knew
they could get away with a whole lot
more
and that's what they set out to do
disney learned this lesson also
the only problem with the current
backlash against grooming especially
disney's grooming of kids isn't that
it's too harsh or over-the-line or too
vengeful or unconstitutional it's none
of those things
the problem is that it's many years too
late
boys like desmond have already been
destroyed while so many conservatives
were distracted or too afraid to say
anything now that we're finally clued in
there is very little we could do
that we could possibly do in holding
disney and other groomers accountable
that would be truly overboard
certainly taking away their special
cushy privileges doesn't even come close
to that
i mean
we could forget about everything else
that disney has done
okay we could put all of that to the
side we could skip over everything and
just focus on this one segment on one
episode of good morning america 2018 and
that would be all by itself
way more than enough to justify
everything that's happening to disney
right now
the only problem would be that it took
too long
taking away tax benefits should be the
least of it
why should a company be able to keep its
tax benefits after putting that on the
air
you answer me that
i want any conservative who has a
problem with this to answer me that why
should they be able to keep their tax
privileges while doing that
in a sane and just and healthy society
all of the adults involved
would would you know the tax privileges
would be the least of it because all the
adults involved in producing and filming
that segment would be in jail if we were
a sane society
desmond's parents would have life
sentences and solitary confinement
at a minimum
the backlash against disney would have
been so overwhelming and intense as to
totally bankrupt and destroy the company
that's what should have happened
what should still happen
instead we have to settle for making
them pay taxes
you know that's not such a steep price
to pay
when you think of it like that
well i hope you enjoyed that clip from
the matt wall show if you did go ahead
and hit that subscribe button right down
there so you can stay up to date on all
of our future content